>> HI, EVERYONE AND WELCOME TO
THE SPECIAL EDITION OF
"HANNITY," FIGHTING THE RADICAL
LEFT.
I'M TAMMY BRUCE IN FOR
SEAN HANNITY.
AND TONIGHT WITH JULY 4TH AROUND
THE CORNER, MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ARE GEARING UP TO
CELEBRATE THE GREATEST COUNTRY
ON PLANET EARTH.
BUT HOLD ONTO YOUR SEATS,
BECAUSE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS A MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT.
ACCORDING TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
THE PRICE OF A JULY 4TH COOKOUT
HAS DECREASED BY AN INCREDIBLE
$0.16.
FORGET ABOUT THE 50% INCREASE IN
GAS PRICES, OR THE 4% RISE IN
HOUSING, OR THE 21% SURGEON USED
CARS, OR THE 124% INCREASE IN
LUMBER.
THANKS TO JOE BIDEN, YOU JUST
SAVED $0.16 ON YOUR COOKOUT,
UNLESS YOU ARE HAVING HOT DOGS.
THE PRICE OF A HOT DOG IS NOW A
10-YEAR HIGH.
BUT JEN PSAKI NEVER LETS THE
TRUTH GET IN THE WAY OF A GOOD
NARRATIVE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Reporter: THE OFFICIAL
WHITE HOUSE ACCOUNT WE DID
YESTERDAY, THE COST OF A
FOURTH OF JULY COOKOUT IS DOWN
$0.16 FROM LAST YEAR?
$0.16?
>> THERE HAS BEEN A REDUCTION IN
SOME OF THE COSTS OF KEY
COMPONENTS OF THE FOURTH OF JULY
BARBECUE, THAT IS WHAT THE TWEET
WAS NOTING.
>> Reporter: DOES THE
WHITE HOUSE THINK THAT $0.16 OFF
A BARBECUE HAS MORE OF AN IMPACT
ON PEOPLE'S LIVES THAN GAS BEING
$1 MORE THIS FOURTH OF JULY?
>> I WOULD SAY IF YOU DON'T LIKE
HOT DOGS YOU MAY NOT CARE ABOUT
THE REDUCTION OF COST.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE
HOT DOGS -- A REDUCTION OF --
>> Tammy: SO DISCONNECTED.
WHILE JEN PSAKI SPENDS IN
CIRCLES, HER BOSS JOE BIDEN IS
FLAT OUT REFUSING TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS BECAUSE IT'S FRIDAY
AND WE ARE HEADING INTO A
HOLIDAY WEEKEND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ASK
ANYMORE -- QUICK QUESTION ON
AFGHANISTAN.
FOURTH OF JULY.
I'M CONCERNED YOU GUYS ARE
ASKING ME QUESTIONS THAT I WILL
ANSWER NEXT WEEK BUT IT MISSED
THE HOLIDAY WEEKEND, I'M GOING
TO CELEBRATE IT, THOSE GREAT
THINGS HAPPENING, THE ECONOMY IS
GROWING FASTEST TIME IN 40
YEARS, RECORD NUMBERS OF NEW
JOBS, COVID DEATHS ARE DOWN 90%,
WAGES ARE UP MORE THAN 15 YEARS.
WE ARE BRINGING OUR TROOPS HOME.
WE HAVE ALL ACROSS AMERICA
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BALL GAMES
AND DOING GOOD THINGS.
THIS IS GOOD.
I'LL ANSWER ALL YOUR NEGATIVE
QUESTIONS -- NOT NEGATIVE, THEY
ARE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS.
>> Tammy: COME ON, MAN.
NO DOUBT JOE BIDEN IS PRIMED AND
READY FOR SOME REST AND
RELAXATION BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE,
HIS RADICAL BASE IS HARD AT WORK
IN THE NEXT ITEM ON THEIR
AGENDA, COURT PACKING AND IF
THEY GET THEIR WAY, THE
INTEGRITY OF THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT WILL IN FACT BE
RUINED FOREVER.
JOINING ME NOW WITH MORE IS
FORMER ACTING DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE
RIC GRENELL, ALONG WITH FORMER
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
BRYCE PREVIOUS.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR COMING ON
HERE, I APPRECIATE IT.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE JOB OF BEING COMMANDER IN
CHEESE, I THOUGHT IT WAS 24/7
ESPECIALLY WITH ALL KINDS OF
THINGS GOING ON IN THE WORLD,
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS
ATTITUDE FROM JOE BIDEN OF I
DON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT AFGHANISTAN, IT IS
THE FOURTH OF JULY, IS THAT A
NORMAL AND SAFE APPROACH FOR THE
PRESIDENT?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL, TAMMY, AND
HAPPY FOURTH TO YOU AND RICK.
NOT AT ALL.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A 24/7 OPERATION
BUT IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT IS
VERY SERIOUS AND WHEN SOMEONE
HAS A QUESTION ABOUT AFGHANISTAN
AND TROOPS THAT ARE LEAVING
AIRBASES THAT HAVE BEEN OCCUPIED
WITH AMERICAN AIRMEN AND
SOLDIERS AND MARINES FOR THE
PAST TWO DECADES, IT'S SOMETHING
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO ANSWER
BUT HE DOESN'T.
IN THE MEDIA GIVES HIM A PASS.
BUT I THINK IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
MORE FUN IF WE PLAYED THE $0.16
GAME AND SEE HOW MANY THINGS WE
CAN ACTUALLY BUY WITH $0.16.
LIKE MAYBE A BUTTON, A
JOLLY RANCHER, PERHAPS.
>> Tammy: NOT EVEN THAT.
THAT IS ABOUT.
>> $0.16 CAN BUY YOU 4% OF A
GALLON OF GAS.
SO TOTALLY OUT OF TOUCH WHILE
COPS ARE GETTING SHOT UP,
OLYMPIC ATHLETES ARE TURNING
THEIR BACK ON THE FLAG AND
180,000 PEOPLE ARE POURING OVER
THE BORDER EVERY MONTH.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN FOR A
RECKONING VERY, VERY SOON.
IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tammy: WHAT'S FRIGHTENING,
AND BOTH OF YOU HAVE BEEN RIGHT
NEXT TO THE SEAT OF POWER THERE
AND WITH THAT $0.16 MEME ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, IT INVITES MOCKERY
AND RIDICULE.
IT KIND OF SIGNIFIES THAT
WHOEVER IS MAKING THIS DECISION
IS COMPLETELY DISCONNECTED.
AND THEY THINK SO LITTLE OF US
THAT THEY THINK WE ARE GOING TO
GET EXCITED ABOUT $0.16.
>> $0.16 WON'T GET YOU ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" PAY WALL,
WHERE ALL OF THE NEWSROOMS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM ARE
CELEBRATING THE $0.16.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., IS THAT THEY
READ EACH OTHER, THEY RETWEET
EACH OTHER, THEY RECYCLE EACH
OTHER'S NEWS, AND THEN THEY GO
INTO THE NEWSROOM AND THEY SAY
WOW, THIS IS SUCH A POPULAR
STORY OF SAVING $0.16 BUT THEY
NEVER REALLY REALIZED THAT THEY
ARE LITERALLY RE-TWEETING AND
AMONGST THEMSELVES.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM OF
WASHINGTON.
IT IS SO INSULAR.
I'M HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
PEOPLE MOCK THIS STORY.
THEY KNOW THAT WHEN THEY DRIVE
TO THE GROCERY STORE, THEY JUST
BLEW THROUGH WAY MORE MONEY THAN
$0.16.
AND THERE IS A WHOLE LIST OF
THINGS THAT ARE MORE EXPENSIVE,
AND SO ONLY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
DOES THIS TYPE OF NARRATIVE
WORK, AND JOE BIDEN WILL KEEP
IGNORING QUESTIONS ABOUT FOREIGN
POLICY BECAUSE HE GETS TO.
THE MEDIA WILL ALLOW HIM TO, ONE
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
BUT WHEN YOU TALK TO REGULAR
PEOPLE, THEY ARE LAUGHING.
>> Tammy: WE KNOW IT'S A
DISCONNECTION BUT IT REALLY IS,
GOING WITH THEM THINKING $0.16
WOULD ROCK OUR WORLD, IT'S
INSANE DURING THE PANDEMIC, WHAT
CONTINUES TO ROCK OUR WORLD IS
$1200 WHICH WOULD MAYBE LAST A
WEEK OR PAY A COUPLE OF BILLS OR
IS GOING TO GET YOU THROUGH MAY
BE TWO WEEKS.
THIS IS WHERE AMERICANS ARE
REALIZING THAT THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR LIVES,
IN OUR CITIES, BECAUSE AS RICK
NOTED, BECAUSE OF THE INSULA ARE
DYNAMIC.
OR DO YOU THINK IT'S POSSIBLE
THEY GENUINELY SIMPLY DO NOT
CARE AT THIS POINT WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO US?
>> NO, I THINK THEY ARE TOTALLY
OUT OF TOUCH, JUST AS YOU AND
RICK HAVE TALKED ABOUT.
I THINK THEY'VE TOTALLY MISREAD
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE STUPID, THAT WE WOULD
ACTUALLY BE EXCITED ABOUT $0.16.
BUT THEY MISREAD THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON COPS, THEY MISREAD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ON THE BORDER,
THEY MISREAD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ON CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
AND YOU KNOW, IN CORPORATE
AMERICA DOVE IN WITH THEM.
THE REGULAR FOLKS ARE LOOKING
AROUND SAYING, WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY?
JUST SIX SHORT MONTHS THAT WE
ARE LOSING NOT JUST THE ECONOMY
IN THIS COUNTRY, WE ARE LOSING
THE AMERICAN CULTURE AND WHAT
MAKES THE FABRIC OF THIS COUNTRY
GREAT.
SO THEY MISTED THE BOAT IN THE
$0.16.
WELL, IT IS FUNNY.
JUST SHOWS YOU HOW BACKWARDS
THEY HAVE THEIR READ ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tammy: HERE WE ARE ON
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
WE KNOW THERE WILL BE NO
FIREWORKS AT MOUNT RUSHMORE.
THERE IS SOME PUNISHMENT GOING
ON THERE.
THERE IS FIREWORKS OF COURSE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS A TIME TO CELEBRATE AND
YET WE'VE SEEN WITH OLYMPIC
ATHLETES ET CETERA,
CONDEMNATIONS OF THE FLAG, OF
AMERICA ITSELF.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
IS REALLY EMBEDDED IN THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY ITSELF?
BECAUSE I'M THINKING THESE ARE
FRENCH ACTORS WHO GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION AND ARE ELEVATED
THROUGH THE SYSTEM ITSELF.
THAT IS PERHAPS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS INFECTING AMERICA AS A
WHOLE.
>> LOOK, I THINK IT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF BOTH.
I'VE BEEN VERY WORRIED OVER THE
LAST YEAR THAT WE HAVE TOO MANY
AMERICANS THAT ARE JUST FALLING
PREY TO GOVERNMENT DIRECTIVES.
WE ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE TOLD
TO STAY IN OUR HOMES AND LOCK
OUR DOORS AND NOT GO OUT.
TO HELP PRACTICES AND COVID,
THEY ARE ALL GOOD BUT THEY ARE
WARNINGS, THEY SHOULDN'T BE
MANDATES.
I HOPE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE START
STANDING UP AND PUSHING BACK.
THE COUNTRY THAT ALLOWS THE
GOVERNMENT TO DICTATE OUR
BEHAVIOR IS THE COUNTRY THAT
FALLS PREY TO TOTALITARIANISM
AND FASCISM PRETTY FAST.
AND I'M REALLY WORRIED THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH AMERICANS
RECOGNIZING WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
IS TRYING TO DO.
WASHINGTON, D.C., CORPORATE
AMERICA, THE MEDIA, THEY ARE ALL
IN ON THIS.
WE'VE GOT TO PUSH BACK AND
PEOPLE NEED TO SPEAK UP AND THEY
NEED TO BE SUPPORTED WHEN OTHERS
SPEAK UP.
TO GO TO FACEBOOK, GO TO
SOCIAL MEDIA, TALK THIS WEEKEND
WHEN YOU ARE CELEBRATING YOUR
FREEDOMS AND YOUR INDEPENDENCE
AND SPEAK OUT, AND DON'T BE
AFRAID.
>> Tammy: I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE LAST WORD HERE.
IF YOU LAST THOUGHTS ABOUT THE,
TEN, 20 SECONDS, WOULD HE THINK
ON THIS INDEPENDENCE DAY WHERE
WE ARE HEADED, IF AMERICANS WILD
ENOUGH.
>> I THINK WE ARE HEADING, IF
NOT IN 2022, POST 2022, WE ARE
HEADED FOR A STEEL CAGE MATCH
POLITICALLY IN THIS COUNTRY.
A LOT OF IT IS GOING TO HAVE TO
DO WITH CULTURAL DECISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE, THE ECONOMY, THE
INFLATION IS GOING TO BE HITTING
THE ROOF.
>> Tammy: THIS IS GOING TO BE
A DISASTER.
>> BUT IT'S GOING TO BE A CALL
TO QUESTION MOMENT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tammy: GREAT WAY TO PUT IT
IN DEED, AND SOMETHING WE ARE
READY FOR, WE ARE THE GENERATION
THAT WAS BORN FO